and welcome to this video newbie 87 and
pretty much like the name suggests I've
never played them Anna Sun drools on
target II some tecate is actually in
order handler there's some 2011 top
figures is he going to play move doesn't
know it does okay yeah maybe it's a sign
again I played a couple of e 5 s
recently so and maybe it's a sewing
again okay let's try something else
playing this funky like the Capri shake
variation and not wow that that's a very
sharp line accepting this capture of
course I've 7s the point maybe I go with
go for 95 if it castles 95 bishop f 79 f
79 f 3 I can go 25 yeah that should
should hold
yeah why does of course taking a huge
strategic risk this is now a case of the
either has to meet me or you will lose
the game on on this weaknesses but there
is some likelihood they have debated
yeah definitely it's very likely that
this kind of player some is good for
black in a correspondence game or impure
analysis but in a new real-life game the
bad development can easily prove fatal
for black that said I really I really
don't see what you should do I mean okay
well here I have g6 right or is there no
Queen takes d5 Wow okay that that it's
good that I spotted this tactic e6 you
can take it six whoa okay oh so maybe 95
was already not good huh of course I
didn't see Quinn take c5 before only now
I did spot this tactic
who
if I go eat six probably have to I have
one particular resource 96b should be
six Bishop b6 g six this might be
possible but you can take of course with
the bishop instead of the night maybe
then g6 still kind of playable so Bishop
takes Knight eggs looks bad you can
still take five huh takes Bishop f77 I
know 95 is no maid but it's closed now
anyway anyway I might still get
checkmated but of course it can just
take this seven yeah mother with a good
position probably takes the 727 tween
most Bishop g7 I mean I'm still kind of
existing but it's very tough yeah if it
takes you five now d5 Bishop f17 795
check I think I can go to the sex i'm
not i'm not seeing a made them
I have a queen up for peace out it
really has to find the direct mail
Bishop d7 looks far more practical at
same check
so I'm not getting checkmated quickly
that that's really good news yeah i mean
i'm not i'm not really enthusiastic
about this here but it looks it looks
kind of kind of okay night to have six
probably i'm up to the edge here alone
let's prevent anything to be five maybe
rook c8 nancy form of course he can
unite have six but i didn't mind that so
much okay here oh he had Knight b6 why
didn't I I didn't address that idea at
all Jesus okay Sheikh he gave her a
shaky game
only good news is he's taking a long
time here for a smooth if I go night can
I not take you for now or what is the
point I don't get it okay I'm just
grabbing this now
take their it's got 92 probably Queen
h4h three it's not leading to much okay
I t doesn't have any great discovery in
the first place I think maybe 90 f six
actually to trade stuff let's try that
yeah okay I'm happy about this now the e
porn is a big target look here maybe oh
no that's not giving me six so easily
hmm ok then going back 48 no f5 you just
use the unprotected State of the rook
g5 this rope to 3f that's not a great
idea maybe just I just want want that
pawn and possibly my dearly with queens
traded check no there you will lose the
depot and see
time work like for its own time oh
that's all the super strong attack yeah
I have no idea about the theoretical
evaluation here but so let's let's see
keep probably this wynia the computer
gives this as a win so I have to go v6
year I have to play six wow yeah of
course I had relied on g6 yeah I didn't
really think Queen age five it's
anything because I thought g6 and what
is he doing there but of course he is
doing something and I can resign because
of that checkmate cute made him Jan that
that left this one now it took this so
Knight takes Knight takes is winning
according to the engine so let's find
out why there's this and then the engine
gives this which I didn't really have on
the radar why is this winning ah this
check ok ok ok ok yeah Queen did I
didn't see the check Queen d70 can just
take take f 7 which is pretty much
disastrous and well ok we cannot talk
about King it Sonia it's completely
ridiculous so that wins am I can go
clean d7 and continue but now k that's a
disaster it took their
yeah and now i'm at least hanging on
even though the position is still not
good of course I mean I'm a porn down
here right I actually didn't really pay
attention to that in the game if you
would have asked me I would have claimed
as equal material but it's not the case
yeah just shuffling here now 9 of six no
I think I'm okay engine says equal yeah
now I'm really okay I really didn't it
really didn't recognize that I'm porn
down I thought I'm just I'm just better
here because of positional
considerations but I'm important Oh
sometimes it's cool if you don't count
on you and now I'm winning this with a
good position yeah okay he was really in
suffering from this this time this time
problem now here what is pretty much
lost there was a very lucky game he had
a winning a tag out of the opening okay
well thanks for watching